[Music]
tasha's in pennsylvania hey tasha what's
up
hi dave i need help we'll try how can we
help
so here's the situation i recently
bought a primary residence
i have a rental property um that i've
owned since 2013. it used to be my
primary
but this new home that i bought is
turning out to be a bit of a money pit
and i need cash to help do renovations
on it
i'm hesitant to sell my rental
but i know that if i do i could be
debt-free
i'm not sure if that's the right choice
because i do make money on it i also
have 47 000 in student loans
so i've got debt i've got equity and i'm
just kind of frozen and i don't know
what to do
well i yeah if you can sell the rental
and have the cash to finish the money
pit and not be a money pit anymore and
have the cash to knock out your student
loans then i'm selling it
uh the question i've got is are you
going down a rabbit hole with this money
pit thing and you need to sell it
it's something i've thought about
but in its current state
i would be losing
tens of thousands of dollars
so i don't
you tore it up after you bought it
so
i bought it knowing it was a fixer-upper
thinking it was going to be cosmetic but
once i started
taking some things down i discovered
some serious structural issues
so there's no equity in the house and to
sell it as it stands
i probably won't even recoup you know
what little i've done so
what'd you pay for it
i paid 96. what would it sell for today
as well
so for today as is
i mean i think
50 60 tops
okay so i would be losing upwards of 30
to 40 000 right off the bat
i think either way needs about 50k in
work too
and then at that point what would it be
worth if you put all this money into it
are you going to recoup it i would
anyway i would have no equity but i
think i would break even if i put in 50
i think it would be worth around 130
140. so i'd probably break even no
equity and i'd have a nice home to live
in and you'd be happy with the home at
that point
i would i would yeah it's just a matter
of funding those
repairs and
i'm hesitant to sell the rental i could
do a cash out refi
and have money to do it i know that's
probably not dave's choice um but well
you've got all this you've got a pile of
debt too sitting there with a student
loan so i like the idea of paying off
the of selling the rental could you pay
off your student loans and have a pile
of cash if you sold the rental
so my rental i bought in 2013 for 150. i
only owe 104
and in this market it's probably worth
350.
i could be debt free i could pay off the
mortgage on the new house with it
i could be totally debt free if i sold
it
the sound of your voice even saying that
sounds like this anxiety is not worth
the money coming in from the rental you
could clean up the student loan debt
have a pile of money and have some money
to to fix your primary residence that
sounds like that's what i would do if i
was in your shoes
yeah because it sounds like this is just
not a fun time for you right now as is
it's not
and on the rental i net about 700 a
month
um so it's
i feel like it's decent but
it could also solve all my problems if i
got rid of it yeah
i think that's the answer that that last
sentence
that's what sums it up right
and um
you know basically this bad decision
has forced you into a corner
on which next decision you make and you
don't want it to be a bad decision
so you know if you don't want to lose
thirty thousand dollars selling
the house as is
and move on with your life and keep the
rental
then um then i would sell the rental and
i'd finish fixing this place up i'm a
little bit afraid that it's more than
50k for you to fix it up but you're
going to have more than 50k so that's
okay
here's what's interesting
when you're doing the fix up with cash
from the rental
that you kind of are pissed about having
to sell it
you're going to be super careful
with the renovation and you're not going
to go overboard because you're using
like real money that came from a source
that you didn't really want to have to
do
and so it's going to kind of make you
very very wise
in your renovation process and and
you'll be a lot calmer in your
innovation process too because you're
not doing it all with borrowed money the
chances are you do a cash out refi and
then let's let's just add to this
equation a bunch of debt
let's add to this mess a big pile of
debt
no that would just be you're just
compounding the stupid then
and no i wouldn't do that but yes i'd
sell your rental here and let's get this
mess cleaned up get the get the mortgage
paid off get the rental fixed or get the
house fixed up and
get the uh
get student loan paid off and you got a
lot of peace in your life at that point